all right everyone thank you for joining
and welcome to
migrating cassandra workloads to cloud
bigtable
uh brief introductions my name is
kristin o'leary i'm a developer
relations engineer and i focus on
big table client libraries and i'm billy
jacobson i'm also a developer relations
engineer
focusing on cloud bigtable sample code
and tutorials
so kristen's going to kick things off in
this presentation by talking about why
you might want to migrate
to bigtable from cassandra and
different application structures you
might have that are fairly common in
cassandra
then with all those applications and
potential
applications there she's going to walk
you through how you would migrate each
of those to
bigtable then once that's done i'm going
to walk you through all the code and
sample resources we have available to
make that process as easy as possible
so kristin why don't you kick things off
thanks billy
yeah so we're going to start with
reasons why you may want to migrate from
cassandra to big table
so we're going to focus on just two
different examples the first is
maybe you're currently struggling to
maintain availability
uh durability and performance of your
current existing distributed database so
some
more examples include maybe you're
struggling with stability at scale
or maybe there's just too much
operational load on your sres
or you're just generally dealing with
overhead of managing replication
repair and things like garbage
collection um
a second point could be you may want to
move up the tech stack and spend
less time and money on things like
managing
uh the different complexities of a
distributed database
so examples here include you know maybe
you want to reduce the total cost of
operation of your infrastructure and
do things that were different than
before and things that weren't possible
before
so now we're gonna walk into some
technical steps um
so first step zero here is you need to
plan for your migration
um so before you dive into a migration
from cassandra to bigtable it's really
important
to deep dive into cassandra use cases
and gain a better understanding of how
bigtable and how they're the same and
how they're different
um you should do things like map
concepts schemas and queries
um from cassandra to cloud bigtable
a quick tip um cassandra primary key
you can look at as the same as equal as
a big table
row key that's a great starting
assumption billy's going to talk about
that later but that's a great place to
start when you're looking and thinking
about this type of migration
next we're going to walk through an
example of a migration
flow so step one you
can look into doing dual rights so
you're currently obviously writing into
your cassandra database
now you want to try and write both into
cassandra and bigtable so
any new data will go into both databases
step two now that you have new data in
cloud bigtable you want to copy over the
old data from cassandra into it so you
want to do
copying of existing data from cassandra
into cloud bigtable
step three optionally you can compare
between the two
so make sure that your data is
consistent between cassandra and
bigtable
step four redirect your read so we're
writing into bigtable and now that the
data should be equivalent to what we had
in the cassandra database
we can also start reading into big
tables so redirect your reads from
cassandra to carpet table
step five uh stop your jewelry so now
we're basically using bigtable to read
and to write
no need to dual write anymore so you can
turn off the writing into your cassandra
database and only focus on bigtable
and step six now you're done and you can
decommission cassandra
okay so next up is migration pass we're
going to talk through four different
migration paths that you may encounter
and how to proceed with them
so here are some examples of common
cassandra migration paths
um and they each have different
migration strategies again we'll look at
them more in detail on each slide
we're going to start with batch load
global
serve so you may have an application
where you load data into
one region and then you may want to
replicate the data out to other serving
regions
so in this example the first thing we
would want to do is rewrite our batch
job to support bigtable so this job that
does all of the writing
you now want to support bigtable as well
as cassandra
um secondly you want to rewrite your api
to support bigtable
so instead of just you know writing to
cassandra now we're writing to bigtable
and now we want to start changing api to
do things like read as well
um step three you want to run your batch
jobs in parallel to run
to load the data both into cassandra and
bigtable
and then finally once you're done um and
once you feel this data is equivalent
you can release to switch your api layer
from cassandra to bigtable entirely
so you'll see here in the diagram first
we had just the
cassandra instance and now we're writing
to bigtable as well to serve the end
users
so next up is when downtime is
acceptable so this is another common
um application instance where your
application may be able to accept some
downtime and have a maintenance window
so um this is an example of how you can
do the migration during that time so
first up you want to stop writing to
cassandra during your migration window
and then you just want to do a big batch
copy from cassandra to bigtable
and so once you've done that the data
should be equivalent
um and you can optionally compare to
ensure that your data is correct
and then switch over your serving layer
entirely to bigtable so
now your api will talk to your bigtable
instead and then you want to
decommission cassandra so you can see
here on the diagram
we've now switched over the api layer to
talk to bigtable as well
next is online with time to live so this
is another common workload where let's
say you have something like a cache or
user sessions where you have data that
eventually will expire
um so we'll use that to our benefit here
so that first up of course we want to
rewrite our code again so that we're
rewriting
we're writing data into both cassandra
and bigtable
so now we're getting all of our new data
into bigtable as well
and then you want to wait until your
time to live expires so once your data
that was only in cassandra has expired
the two databases should be equivalent
um
again you can do things like do
asynchronous callbacks to verify that
the data is consistent between the two
and then finally you can decommission
cassandra so again as you see in the
diagram we've written to
both the cassandra and bigtable and then
eventually due to the time to live
both sets will become equivalent
and last but not least we have online
with persistent data
this is a workload that's user facing
semi-transactional
can't accept any type of downtime so how
do we work in that case
um so you want to again rewrite your api
layer to
read and write to both systems and then
ensure there's managed consistency in
the api layer just in case something
goes down
um you want to batch copy and backfill
your data into bigtable because again
you can't accept any downtime
um and then you want to do asynchronous
callbacks between the two
again and then we keep saying this to
make sure that your data is consistent
and equivalent and then once you're
satisfied with the consistency of your
data
you can shut down all right so we've
talked about a lot of different um
situations and examples now billy is
going to take us through some of the
actual
code that you will use if you want to do
a migration from cassandra to bigtable
yeah thank you so much kristen um we've
got a lot of starting points from there
so
from those paths you are going to take
there are two major aspects to your
migration
migrating your queries and doing your
batch data migration
so let's first look at migrating queries
and if you're using cassandra or any
kind of database you have a lot of
queries you're going to want to migrate
so
you're managing your tables with queries
any kinds of garbage collection with
queries you're writing your data you're
reading data
and you might also have analysts that
need to perform table-wide analytics and
are more comfortable with sql than some
of the programming languages that we
have client libraries for
so i'm going to walk you through a bunch
of examples and they are all available
later in this code lab cloud bigtable
for cassandra users you can learn the
basics of migrating a lot of these
queries
and all the code that's in these slides
will be available there so
don't feel you need to pause the video
to figure out what the code is you can
find the link later
so let's look at an example database
just to make things a little bit more
concrete through these examples
so we're storing um data about mobile
devices in a time
series so we have information about
their cellular plan how much data each
phone has
if it's connected to the wi-fi connected
to a cell tower
and which operating system it's on and
you might have a lot more data in here
we also are storing the device type a
device id
and the date that that data is stored on
and we could store that in the row
but we've also we've upgraded it into
our row key
because this is where we are doing our
queries from this is very similar to our
cassandra primary key
so all your queries for the table are
going to be based on your roki kristin
mentioned earlier
your primary key can be pretty much
translated into your row key by just
concatenating
the important parts of it so here we
have device type
device id and date and the big
big table queries are based on row gets
based on the roki and row range scans
based on the row keys as well
so these features are really going to
determine
which queries are going to be the most
performant
so to get started with bigtable you're
probably going to use
our command line utility which is
similar to the cassandra shell and this
is called the cpt tool here i'm showing
you how to create a table
with with the cvt tool and
we and you'll notice with cassandra
you're used to defining all the columns
in advance defining your primary key
and we don't do that in big table we
just define the table name
and any column families and you can
define
your garbage collection rules at the
column family level
so the cbt tool is great for doing
creating your tables getting everything
set up but you can also use it for
reading and writing data
deleting data managing your app profiles
managing your garbage collection
and if you have any scripts for database
automation that you have set up maybe
using cassandra shell or anything like
that
the cvt tool is a great way to just swap
those out
if you're switching over to bigtable but
for your application you're probably
going to want to use one of our client
libraries
we have our client libraries available
in eight languages
or in eight programming languages go
java python
node.js just name a few and we have
documented
all the different ways you're probably
gonna wanna use bigtable there
so we're gonna just look at the java
client um but again all those
all those other client libraries will be
well documented with
uh examples similar to these so here for
writing data
we in cassandra you're used to doing an
insert you're going to specify the
columns and their values
where bigtable we do writes as mutations
so
we'll take our row key and create a
mutation from that where we
set a cell's value so the cells are an
intersection of the
row key the column family and column and
then we provide a value for it
and you'll also note here we're
providing a time stamp
bigtable will let you store multiple
versions of a value or multiple values
at different versions in a cell
and you can use that as part of your
time series storage strategy
and with garbage collection you can
determine how many versions are kept or
how old those versions are
so one of the parts of your migration is
going to be dual rights potentially
so to do that you're going to pick your
client library of choice
and then alongside any of your
insertions you're going to create a
mutation
to match that alongside of it
so now let's look at two select
statements
here we're just selecting one row
because we're selecting on
all the parts of the primary keywords
we've got the device type
the device id and a date and in big
table
we're just going to translate that into
a row key by concatenating all that
information
and here we're using a um the pound
symbol to separate each
each um each piece of information but
you can you really use any symbol you
want
so we take our row key and we just
perform again and you can do whatever
you want with the data
from there so if you wanted to
verify that your data had been migrated
correctly you could query
cassandra and bigtable at the same time
wrap those in an
asynchronous callback block and then log
any deviations
that you get until everything is
matching or you sort out any of those
errors
so you can also do this for multiple
rows here we're scanning for
all the um dates or all the dates after
2019 or kind of just 20 20 at this point
for a specific phone so
when bigtable we can do a prefix scan
for that
we're going to instead of doing the full
row key we just take part of the row key
so we're taking the device type
phone and the device id which is 4c41
whatever it is
and then we're just taking the year
because all the data for
that device and all the data for the
device that's in 2020 will have that as
its prefix for their scan
so we pass that prefix to the scan and
then we can get all the rows for that
and you can use this in multiple ways so
let's say you want to get all the data
for 2020 and 2019
you could do two prefix scans and do
them and
you could pass you could create a scan
which is two prefixes at once
and get all that data back at once
and you kind of perform queries and
creative ways to do that but
if you're going to have a little bit
more nuance in your queries than what
the roki can provide
maybe just for one-off quiz you're
trying to learn
new things about your data you're going
to use filters and this is very similar
to
allow filtering in cassandra so we have
time stamp filtering
value filtering you could do row key
regexes if part of the row key is going
to help you out
but again like cassandra with allow
filtering you don't want to
let it just do full table scans so we
recommend that you
have a range as part of that query or do
a prefix scan just to limit
how much data you're going to be
scanning with that filter
and then a final option for migrating
your queries to bigtable
is to use bigtable as an external data
source
on a bigquery and this is just easy this
is really easy to
set use a configuration file to
translate some of your data into
bigquery and then you can do table-wide
analytics on it with
a sql-like language so this is a lot
more performant for your table-wide
analytics
you can save some of the data after you
query it to big
query to hand that to an analyst if they
just want to run a lot of queries on the
same set of data
or we actually see a lot of customers
write data to bigtable and bigquery and
they use them
they use the data warehousing features
of bigquery and the
speed and qps that bigtable provides as
a database
so that's all about how to migrate your
queries but most of the scenarios that
kristen went through include a batch
data migration and
we know this can be intimidating you
have a lot of data you don't want to
lose it you want to make sure it all
stays in sync
so we've made it super easy with our
bulk load tool
this is going to run on cloud data flow
our managed and hosted apache beam
runner
it does an automatic schema conversion
for you it'll copy the data and there's
no coding needed
you'll just pass in your configuration
file with the tables
key spaces and server information and
then you can run it with the command
line
um and what's great is this is all open
source so
if you want to take our um our bulk load
tool and make it work from
some more of your specific requirements
feel free to do that and
apache beam uh and on apache beam we
have the cassandra io
big table aisle and even bigquery i o
connector so
you can write any sort of pipelines that
connect these three to make whatever
to make whatever data flow is going to
work best for you
so now you understand why you might want
to migrate
how to determine the path to get from
cassandra to bigtable
you can do your dual rights data
verifications and your batch data
migration
so what are you going to do next if
you're an existing customer
we recommend that you connect with one
of your account teams to get started
they'll help connect you to
a lot of the resources we have but if
you're not you can check out some of
these links we've got
um we here's a link to the code lab i
mentioned earlier so you can get started
on seeing how your queries are going to
migrate
and you can even check out a talk from
cloud next 2019 where spotify discusses
how they migrated from cassandra to big
table using a lot of the techniques
and tools from this talk thank you so
much for attending and happy migrations
you